black panther smashed projections with a
record-breaking 235 million dollar
four-day total making it the fifth
largest domestic opening weekend of all
time despite debuting in February which
is usually one of the slowest months of
the year so how did it manage to crush
expectations and take over the cultural
consciousness here's a look at how Black
Panther blew everyone away at the box
office
royal reviews most films in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe have garnered
positive reviews but Black Panther took
it to the next level enjoying widespread
critical acclaim how widespread the film
currently holds a 97% score on Rotten
Tomatoes making it the best reviewed
superhero film of all time even above
the Dark Knight building buzz months
before its release Black Panthers
started building incredible
word-of-mouth
the movie's teaser trailer scored 89
million views in the first 24 hours
after its highly promoted debut during
Game four of the 2017 NBA Finals making
it one of the most viewed trailers ever
for any Disney film that buzz
immediately spilled over onto social
media with the movie's generating more
mentions on Twitter than the NBA game
during which it debuted this continued
throughout the lead-up to the film and
helped the movie earn second place on
Fandango survey of the most anticipated
films of 2018 after only Marvel's
Avengers infinity war black panther has
since become the most tweeted about
movie of 2018 a distinction it achieved
even before it hit theaters excited
audiences Black Panther continued to
build on that buzz when it hit theaters
earning an A+ cinema score from opening
AI viewers only the second Marvel movie
to do so after the Avengers and many
fans lined up to see Black Panther
multiple times as Fandango reported that
the movie had a significantly higher
number of repeat viewers than any other
film during its opening weekend Dave
Hollis Disney's president of the actual
distribution said it's not like anything
we've ever experienced before it has
taken on its own life the way people are
talking about the experience is that I
saw it on Thursday but I'm coming back
on Saturday and might be back on Tuesday
the Black Panther challenge the
excitement moved off social media as
well grassroots events at pop
across the United States surrounding the
film with activists using the movie as a
way to bring their communities together
philanthropist Frederick Joseph launched
the black panther challenge to raise 40
thousand dollars to help kids in Harlem
see the film but the challenge has sent
spiraled out even further resulting in
over six hundred thousand dollars raised
by a number of campaigns from
celebrities and regular people alike the
challenge brought more positive buzz and
excitement to the film while bringing
the movie-going community together in
support of a good cause anything's
possible you're capable of doing
anything you put your mind to something
you can achieve it big screen
representation much of the buzz
surrounding Black Panther is thanks to
its predominantly black cast something
rarely seen in big screen blockbusters
Black Panther marks the first time a
black superhero is leading a movie in
the modern MCU and it's also an
important milestone behind the camera
with Ryan Coogler becoming the first
black director of a Marvel movie this
was reflected in the movie's audience
according to The Hollywood Reporter 37%
of the opening-weekend audience for the
movie was african-american compared to
an average of 15% for other superhero
films Disney's Dave Hollis said our goal
is to make movies that reflect the
diversity of our world because those are
the stories that resonate everywhere to
have the ability to show other people's
experience is part of the beauty of
movies but it also allows for rich
storytelling and for the people whose
experiences are up on the screen
especially if they have not been
showcased 2-ton the meaningful nature of
being able to see yourself represented
those things really matter to everyone
but in this case it matters even more to
communities of color representation
matters and the times we've leaned into
it we've had massive results what Black
Panther means to me
Black Panther has a special place in the
hearts of many viewers and they took the
social media with the hashtag what Black
Panther means to me to express their
enthusiasm about the movie the hashtag
was created by Kayla Sutton the director
of online marketing for black girl nerds
and was inspired by her eight-year-old
son one Twitter user wrote it means that
my kids and young black kids everywhere
will see themselves as heroes capable of
leading their own narratives while
another said that the movie meant
everything I cried when it was announced
I cried at the visuals I
cried at the SDCC Marvel booth I cried
in joy their blackness is mine
my blackness is theirs black panther is
a love letter a celebration and a
victory March for the Diaspora
the outpouring on social media helped to
build even more buzz for the movie and
it helped solidify its place as a
cultural milestone strong female
characters Black Panther also received a
lot of praise for its strong female
characters led by Lupita Nyong'o is
Nakia Danai gurira Sequoyah latisha
writes Cherie and angela bassett Ramona
as was the case with the 2017 box office
hit Wonder Woman female audiences turned
out in full force to support these
powerful ladies 45 percent of the
opening weekend viewers were women
compared to 35 to 40 percent for most
superhero movies the movies badass women
also got a lot of attention on social
media with one tweet calling Cherie the
Disney princess I've been waiting my
whole life for no major challengers most
Marvel movies don't face huge
competition as other Studios avoid
scheduling movies opposite Marvel's many
blockbuster juggernauts and black
panther was no exception as it faced
almost no competition for minor new
releases early man and samson and the
forecast looks good as well as the next
major new release isn't until March 9th
when Disney drops its next blockbuster a
wrinkle in time which also features a
black director and a black lead looks
like black panther isn't just king of
Wakanda he's king in the box office -
long live the king
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]